it's hurt for me not to ask you this I'm
sure you've had others ask you as well
but in your heart do you think had it
been you versus Donald Trump that you
could have defeated him you know who
knows what the polling showed early on
is that in almost all the polls
nationally and statewide I was beating
them by pretty large margins much more
so than Secretary Clinton you know but
then you go through a three-month
campaign I all I could tell you Conan I
wish to God that I had had that
opportunity I would have loved I had one
other question that occurs to me in the
moment is that the media and many people
say the Clinton campaign read the
situation incorrectly didn't see what
was happening in the Rust Belt were you
aware yeah I was I was look let's be
clear there's a lot of pain in America
what a pain I was when all over this
country you know I went to Native
American reservations well life
expectancy is the equivalent of what it
is in Guatemala I went to communities in
West Virginia and Kentucky where people
today if you can believe it are dying at
younger ages than their parents did
because of despair because of low wages
the turning to alcohol drugs suicide
I've been in communities in this country
minority communities for African
American youth unemployment 20 30 40
percent people are hurting and what
Trump managed to do is to convince
people that he of all people was the
anti-establishment candidate at a time
when people really are not happy with
the economic establishment the political
establishment or the media establishment
I think sadly the much of what he said
will turn out not to be true that he's
not going to keep his word but that's
what he told the American people that he
will stand up to Wall Street they he
will protect Social Security and
Medicare that he will rebuild America
well let's see what he does but let us
be clear not everybody who voted for
Donald Trump is a racist or a sexist or
a homophobe there are a lot of people
who are hurting very badly they saw him
as a
Limor of hope that's why they voted for
me but my job is now as part of the
Democratic leadership is just to rally
the American people around a progressive
agenda which demands that our government
our economy not just work for the 1% but
work for the middle class and working
families and we've got to do that
together
from my perspective from my perspective
and I think I speak for a lot of people
this was a incredibly dreary campaign
but a big glimmer of hope is that you
seemingly came out of nowhere and you
inspired so many young people with and
it was not pie-in-the-sky rhetoric you
were telling them something that wasn't
always easy to hear and it what you've
got an emotional response and I always
look for the optimistic despite
everything and I would think that you
would feel some hope after the reception
that you've gotten over the last year
and the movement you created Coenen I
was through 46 states in this country
and we had some great rallies we had
them here in California all over America
and what I want to say for everybody we
have an incredible generation of young
people black and white and Latino and
Native American Asian American great
young people who love this country very
very deeply and want to transform this
country and make it the kind of country
that we know we can become we are the
wealthiest nation in the history of the
world and when we work together and put
our minds to it and when we have the
courage to take on some very powerful
special interest Wall Street and the
drug companies and the insurance
companies if we have the guts to do that
there is nothing that we cannot
accomplish
[Applause]
our revolution our revolution by senator
bernie sanders and real honor to have
you on the show thank you
[Applause]
you